what's up reject nation greg and john
here we're gonna watch the mandalorian
season two
episode three today of course excited to
check this out got a couple of comments
about this because some of you guys saw
my youtube story i put up the other day
or like at 3 30 in the morning i tried
getting my reaction to the finale of
clone wars up i've done many edits keeps
getting blocked worldwide
i sent it over to our editor for the
mandalorian to
try to cut it himself and so i could put
it up early next week speaking of which
eric robert chronic thank you so much
for editing this for us buddy he does
such an amazing job it's edited for us
so many times in the past edits for
other people give him a follow today
he's earned it full length reaction
watch alongs for
mandalorian will be over at our patreon
page where you sync up with the time
code over there we cover so many shows
where we do watch alongs for them and
many shows where we have the option for
reaction highlights and watch long at
the same tier
shows like supernatural doctor who
jojo's bizarre adventure
avatar the last airbender a whole bunch
thank you so much to everyone who's
become a patronage this holiday season
your support means a hell of a lot
also make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our reaction to the next
mandalorian episode is up let's make an
action very cool
once we're through the atmosphere there
should be just enough fuel to slow us
down
if we don't burn to a crisp
use those retro rockets
what a terrifying way to land
what a terrifying way to land oh buddy
who directed this episode keep it steady
here we go
engage reverse thrusters brace
damn that is shot so well almost there
almost there razor crest you are falling
razor crest you're not listening to me
are you
oh that's that's good look how unfazed
he was the whole time just like is this
guy gonna land
i love his cable
no i just love my man's cable
sweater over here
better hubby
go go frog lady
do you have all the eggs every egg did
you count them
did you count them before landing
oh that's so adorable oh
sasha banks all right close
we enough oh damn what's this thing
going to look like
we'll feed her in the early morning but
we missed that because we were going out
whoa
what
are you kidding me sick
yes oh [ __ ]
oh i think this is the night owls
take that squidward i i think that's
mochita
yes
holy crap that was intense
i've been quested to deliver this child
i was home
it's her
[Music]
oh she's part of the team
you are not mandalorian is one of them
one of what were children of the watch
are a cult of religious zealots that
broke away from mandalorian society
their goal is to re-establish the
ancient way
there is only one way the way of the
mandalore the way
that this is that is so cool that they
like
they brought her here you killed my
brother
i've been quested with returning this
child to the jedi
this thing looks like yoda
i can lead you to one of their kind a
sokkatano
but first we need your help on our
mission of course you do
that's so cool like katie sackoff is in
the show yeah it's so cool
i love that i love that
oh
oh yeah pirates again
bloody pirates damn who directed this
episode
boom boom
[Music]
you're working really hard mando yeah
yeah that's the one thing about this
show is
every character that shows up i'm like
this is so pretty somebody special
oh my god she is so great i think we
have been trapped sir
where
hi copy thanks for packing up all this
gear so nicely
this is more than i signed up for
there is something i need if i am to
rule mandalore something that was
dark saber you're changing the terms of
the deal
this is the way
if you weren't so badass i would have
more issues with you
i'll live the empire
i like this is also giving you a glimpse
of what it's like to be on the empire
payroll
we're moving out too fast we need to
move now
still dropping oh come on dinger and get
your ass in there come on d
cover me this is his show after all
oh damn ugh
come on now i'm at the front i'm the
leader i'm the show
it's my show guys haven't let me help at
all
[Music]
you might let me live but he woke
whoa oh damn where can i find
the jedi god damn
take the foundling to the city of
caledon on the forest planet of corvus
there you'll find us oh [ __ ]
confirmed this is the way
this is the way we will tell everyone
you were a badass
oh don't don't
don't come on it's time to go
let go oh so close
my god jesus
got more personality now though yeah
it's it's rustic
it's lived in
oh no what the
[Music]
egg
it's gonna be a bumpy ride
oh good that was gonna be my next
question bryce dallas howard awesome
wow that was uh i mean she did a good
job in the first
season but damn that was bad that was a
pretty standout episode we appreciate
it lifestyle i'm glad i brought her back
that was awesome
have they done that already where they
took it she like just might be the first
major character they brought from the
animated world
and brought her to live action with the
voice and they cut her hair and died ah
yes all right that's shitty chatty all
righty
wow okay what an episode that was the
air i should have guessed
should have guessed the heiress
referring it's in reference to bocaton
should put that together by no means a
star wars expert i mean i haven't seen
rebels i know what happens in rebels
just because i feel like i had to know
so i'm trying to like cram in some
episodes of rebels right now in the
final season just so i could really
get a little bit more of the additional
experience but there were enough clues
from watching
clone wars to be like oh yeah it's
definitely bo katan they're going to
talk with i mean looking here online
sasha makes his character his name
koska reeves they might have said it at
one point i might have just missed it
the way how
she was watching dinjarin and and baby
yoda at the beginning
reminding me of in the final season of
clone wars
when they were originally watching
ahsoka tano before they asked her for
help
to reclaim mandalore it seems to be
bogota's forever mission
which is to constantly have to reclaim
mandalore
because what else did if she finally
does
they reclaim it at the end of clone wars
with ahsoka tano's help
and then she gets the dark saber from my
understanding to unite the mandalores
and then now she's back at it yeah i
need to unite the clans
this is what i gotta do but you know
there's there's a classic
uh quality of star wars to revitalize
old conflicts
yeah them anew but it was so great to
see her her
outfit brought exactly to life when i
saw her her mandalore outfit i'm like
oh the night out that's her i know there
was a little bit of
some fan backlash in the sense of how
they didn't cast the actors who voices
ahsoka tano
to play a sogutano i mean we'll see how
rosario dawson does i'm assuming she's
going to do a great job it's rosario
dawson
specifically katie sackoff i mean yeah
she she looks like her
you know i i actually don't know what
the actress who plays ahsoka tunnel
looks like
so i can't comment on that but when it
comes to katie sackoff
of course like her voice is going to be
the same bringing the body language of
her to life
and even just her her face just looks
like
bo katan so it's like wow she looks
plucked straight out of the show
that's amazing that's awesome you know
and she did a great job here she did an
amazing job here there's a lot of little
references and easter eggs i think you
could pick up on she calls him the child
of the watch which i
i believe is part of the you feel free
to correct me i'm always looking to
learn more when
especially in the past year and a half
two years as much as people
will kind of crap on the way how star
wars fan bases can be i also feel like
there's the other side where a lot of
people have been very kind enough to
further educate in a non-bullying way
which i always love
so enthusiastic way yeah cause i i do
love learning more and more and more
because i grew up on the movies
it's only in the past couple years where
i've really been wanting to
further educate myself and i've found
like a
refreshed love for diving deeper into
the lore
and you know checking out some of the
video games and the shows now and such
so yeah i mean if there's anything i'm
missing or i get wrong please feel free
to correct me because i want to learn i
believe the child of the watch is a is a
part of the death watch which is what
bo katan was original was originally a
part of you see dinjarin in the first
season and this reference here how he
was saved by the child of the watch
so there is this like kind of
interesting connection there meet
instantaneously with boca ton make sure
i get my facts all right but regardless
of
of any facts or whatever it does a great
job even if you haven't seen the
the clone wars or anything like that as
much as i'm able to pick up on a little
bit more additional nuances and such i
think even if you haven't seen the show
you'll still be able to follow what's
happening yeah yeah i mean i i didn't
have any trouble
what was happening and i yeah i mean
i've seen some auxiliary videos that
involve certain elements of the clone
wars and uh the other shows and whatnot
but this for me as
as somebody who doesn't have quite as
much familiarity was cool because
i like that they actually started to at
least expand a bit on mandalorian lore
within this show because
there has been so much discussion of it
and there's there's like a really long
video i remember we watched once on the
whole history and stuff but to have it
you know
come out of the ether around the show
and right into the show
yeah i thought was a really nice thing
and also you know it's called the
mandalorian and i would assume that
we're also
gonna through the show probe what this
culture and lifestyle is and i like that
idea of them having that immediate clash
of like
you guys are taking your helmets off
that's another way i do things and then
you get this idea that okay well there's
been a fracturing
of you know ideals and factions within
even this religion yeah so uh yeah i
don't know it got me excited
on a level of i know how important this
character
poketan is but also then having an
expansion on the serial side of the
story because then we get our promissory
of okay
then socatano's coming up either next
episode or the episode after
still keeping again that episodic
there's only one step at a time
feels like every episode is literally
setting up where we want to get to
next episode and then we're gonna see
how we get to the point of
arriving there through this episode and
so now having that zoom out to a point
where okay
it's still episodic but now i can feel
the big
cereal arc taking more hold we're
halfway through the season
yeah uh yeah it just felt really nicely
timed especially on the heels
of starting the season off so gradually
it felt like oh we're getting that rush
of anticipated characters and world
expansion
but again with a natural pace and a
natural
smoothing of it for me again into the
show because you know sometimes i feel
like there's a factor where you can feel
left out or like clearly like oh damn
there's like a bunch of stuff i missed
because i haven't seen all this
supplementary material but i didn't have
that experience here they mentioned the
court ahsoka tunnels on corvus and i'm
i'm not familiar
with that i don't i'm not familiar
corvus glaive
game i don't know if i've seen that
planet before
maybe we have maybe we haven't but it's
also going gonna fill in the gaps of
whatever's happened and also about the
purge too because uh boca ton says she
fought in the great purge
so yeah i mean this is one of those
episodes that's making my mind go like
okay where's this really
all going right now where what path are
we headed down he's really going to
learn about the jedi and then like you
said that is a part of what is explored
in the clone wars 2
is the difference in philosophies
ideologies beliefs within subsets of the
mandalores re-establishing
that danjarin is part of a the much more
ancient culture side
going into the the episode itself though
i thought it was shot
beautifully and you know you see the mon
calamari brought to life and this part
of their culture and then i don't know
the name of the
the ones who are not the hmong calamari
squidward
squidward i forget the names of them
that moment when
they knocked amando and baby yoda oh god
into that creature on this ship
that was really intense the way the
sequences were shot i thought bryce
dallas howard exceptionally upped her
game
in terms of capturing action uh the
intensity
of the situations i mean if there's one
thing i would have liked a little bit
more of it is a slightly more enhanced
level
of of threat when it comes from the
empire members they were fighting
against here
it's a common complaint about
stormtroopers they never really feel all
that threatening waiting for that point
where the show really
nails that of yeah this does feel
intense and the stakes feel like
they might not be able to get out of
this particular situation or like they
might lose something along the way
yeah all four of them you know yeah just
completely own the situation
but also showing us the great deed that
they did
dinjarin you know had a a personal
motive
in mind to helping out this frog lady
character but it was such a beautiful
moment when the frog lady unites with
their hubby
and there seems to be some type of
special
link there happening i i think it's so
silly the whole thing with cancel baby i
think it's so dumb
it's the circle of life and it's
conflicting sometimes but he didn't try
eating the frog when it came out he
seems to have this connection to it more
than just he's hungry or maybe that is
just
it there is something about the way they
capture it though that seems to be
hinting at something more well you know
it's the same as like the way eggs are
tasty to eat but also baby chicks are
adorable and you want to have one
yeah you know but i love that yeah they
even kept them they weren't the focus of
this episode they're really just kind of
being coded out of the last episode but
i like that they were even still a
presence in that whole little sidebar
okay i'm gonna leave the child with you
that you know didn't turn into anything
like super sinister but it was just
another one of those aspects that really
makes the world staying
feeling fleshed you know what else kind
of felt like there was a theme
of not resurrection um or like
rebuilding
and in a way you have what the frog lady
and her husband you have with bo katan
wan this rebuilding element even with
the empress
across the empire empire this seems to
be a battle for
rebuilding and uh reuniting which i
thought was a neat theme to hone in on
but man that action was just so cool i
mean let's face it guys that actually
was
really badass so it didn't finally seem
off gideon again
yeah well and just and going to the
action i loved i think the biggest
impact that that registered on me this
episode was like the sense of scope
especially when they're like falling out
of the sky
like the sense that you're falling and
kind of getting caught up in that and
feeling how it like heavy and unwieldy
the gravity can be with these things
like i thought this episode really
punched on those things especially
it was well done on the character scenes
while not on the action scenes
just like really strong across the board
and lori in season two
episode three chapter 11 is it chapter
11 chapter 11.
it looks like we're finally going to see
a socatano in the next episode
[Music]
she'll show her face for like one second
and then you know disappear into the
background i really
i'm really anticipating how they're
going to bring her to life they really
brought bo katana to life in terms of uh
her
fighting abilities and ahsoka tano is
like very acrobatic
a wide variety of martial arts moves
that are like compowera-esque does a lot
of flipping and all these things and of
course she's master wielder
of dual lightsabers and such how are
they going gonna bring her to life
are they gonna go all out in terms of
that you know is she gonna swoop in and
save
them from like a forest beast or is it
gonna be one of those like low-key
introductions where it's like oh we know
she's gonna get crazy in a little bit
but for right now we're going to play it
coy
you know what i would appreciate i
definitely don't have time to watch all
the rebels you guys want to like
write down essential rebels episodes
before going into the next one
i'd appreciate that i've already got the
ending of it ruined for me i still
would like to i like getting the
experience of it more than just you know
information
um i have to get information but i also
love it when i can actually
feel the emotional experience of it as
well i like to experience all my shows
in
cheat sheet bullets and i got it and i'm
done
and this guy who played the imperial
captain what is his titus
yeah he said he's an agent's shield he
looks like he's supernatural also
i think he yeah he's one of the horsemen
he's uh he is right right
wrath the wrath oh damn he got his
finger cut off
i called him wrath and i and i still
haven't learned it yeah yeah he's a
character
so familiar he's been in everything over
the years
too he's like danny houston i feel like
we got name drop supernatural though
because of
that's one of the shows we watch leave
your thoughts down below in the episode
feel free to add any additional
information that would be useful to know
going into the next episode or to
enhance the experience of this episode
subscribe click the notification bell
hit the like button last but not least
let's do a pic
j and valente john wanted to shout you
out go for it jn
i just wanted to wish you well you're
out there somewhere in the universe
lord knows where but i hope your eggs
are safe
i hope that you found allies you can
trust
i hope no one is challenging your chosen
religion
and uh honestly i i hope you're doing
well because even though it's very
sporadic whenever we hear from you it's
it's always like the most distinct and
interesting
stream of thoughts and ideas one day
people will be
studying you and your mind
and trying to glean the essence of
humanity from it but for right now
i hope you're staying safe and uh
adventuring and and being fulfilled love
you jan
pieces you kept it under a minute good
job that's i was all that's all the time
i didn't actually focus on what i was
saying i was just looking at the clock
up there
jn complete 60 seconds
thanks jn miss you buddy we'll talk soon